yeah there's a microphone checking in
the house
100
that's cool
that's how we're starting this podcast
ladies and gentlemen we're starting it
off we're starting with a mic check that
was so hilarious and i'm sure y'all are
gonna
stick around to see what kind of
ad-libbed wrapping we're gonna be doing
while checking our mics is this a
special edition podcast
there's a special thanksgiving podcast
this is a thanksgiving special welcome
to the thanksgiving special here on
corridor cast thanks for joining us
everybody uh it's good to be here we've
got
a colorful cast of characters
indeed we're on the show today we've got
we got matt you you know jake you know
what's special about this podcast to me
is i have never been on a corridor cast
with dean this is the first one yeah
nice to meet you yeah yeah hi dean how
are you
doing is on the podcast today ladies and
gentlemen i mean look at look at that
young handsome face right dude i'm the
youngest guy you've ever seen
i'm the youngest guy
that's right he's younger than dean
that's why he's a child that's why they
call him child beater dean because well
you know he's so young that's just
that's what he fights children right but
they're the same age
in looks yes so no they are so it's
actually over 18 yeah but they act like
children he's punching up
that's right that's what you should do
kids yeah absolutely and of course we
got sam gorski you never know what's
going to happen when sam's on the cast
literally never yeah
i mean last time we sat out to talk
about the things i want to talk about in
this podcast and it turned into a game
of single-player dungeons and dragons oh
yeah
it got um very weird it's very yeah
yeah
so that happened last time and and uh
i think we had a great time but um
you know let's move on yeah we've moved
on from that yeah yeah that's in the
past there's no that's a one-off
yeah you've been requesting it all week
but it's a one-off yeah
much like the rift cast and
the revolution i think we did two we did
a couple of those yeah yeah this one i
think this was a spin-off of the rift
cast you know
yeah this was like uh at least
definitely a sub genre yeah yeah you
guys are always anyways shenanigans down
here
yeah and that's i think i think it's
been too long since dean i think since
you've been on this cast so i think i've
only been on once well well
here's to number two right here buddy
yeah i made a guest appearance on the
smash podcast because you know for some
reason they decided to do without me
you know even though i'm the champ well
can we talk about that right now and we
can't talk about that until the video
comes out can we
no it's okay though
it's kind of boring yeah it's kind of
funny yeah sure sam for you no we have a
whole video about it yeah you're sorry
i'm a loser that's why yeah
it's boring because he's a little loser
uh that's all we can say don't spoil it
for anybody yeah no spoilers
just all you need to know is we did the
2021 smash journey here at the studio
the other day
things got wild and
it's an incredible
finish like it is uh you know every year
feels like an anime storyline this was
like yeah very primo i really wish i was
it is
it surprises me every year
how
there's just still more to come from the
same place
like i thought that you know two years
ago
when it was the hype was so real
that
that once that was that was it it was
like we can't go any no dude we can't go
any higher it gets better it gets more
and more
heated every year
and like people coming in it's just yeah
it's gotten now it's it's it's to the
point where if it continues on the
trajectory that it's on
you're talking about like generational
you know
oh absolutely combat
going on in the future
like gideon is going to be facing off
against milo yeah and
it's true yeah you know they gotta start
training right now it's gonna be like a
place beyond the pines kind of situation
niko's training right wait is that has
that been can i say
you can't oh that that's uh for him to
talk about i'm sure
yeah
that was a lie that was it yeah
leaked
that's a crouton leak right there well
okay but going circling back so the
smash conversation
um
the disappointing thing for me is life
decided to get me sick the very day yeah
whatever man that's what they all say
dude look no seriously though i was just
this was the first day that i was like
or the first year that i was actually
really hyped about the smash not dude i
was like i actually enjoy the game now
i'll be honest man i pulled up a level
nine pac-man to train against um
i was i was you know i've seen your
improvement getting a little better
jordan allen also had to miss it
he he his his girlfriend's roommate got
coveted or something so he we he had to
stay away from the studio for a few days
just to make sure
um the worst part is i was sick for the
day and that's it the next day i was
like pretty much fine i'm like cool man
awesome well then there's the flu the
flu's been going around like i got i got
the flu like just this last week and it
was just like a 12-hour thing right and
then it was gone i know a bunch of
people who've gotten it yeah
how how was your training dean let's
talk about that for a second i mean
because there were some interesting
there were some interesting covert
training techniques that i was hearing
you know i was in town the week leading
up to it and i was hearing all kinds of
strategies that were being sort of
said
whispered if you will
um
i literally i cracked open the game at
home for the first time in a long time
like the night before
and started training i actually
i'm trying to take it less seriously
because i think i i invest maybe a
little too much into this into this
video a little too much emotion
yeah so i uh i'm ramping it down but uh
i think you know there were some people
here who were training
some of them were training very hard i
know there are some people who are like
i can't wait to stop playing this game
after the tournament so can i can i ask
another question on this front since
this is very interesting to me as a
non-player oh yeah at what point did you
sort of
realize in
to you that maybe you're taking it too
far
um i think there's a point where you
just get so good that it's not fun for
anybody else
and
i just didn't want to i didn't want to
go past that point so i kind of had to
like let the you know put on a little
fat as it were yeah they've done they've
done psychological studies on that and
apparently like
rats and other like mammals social
mammals need to like let other people
win 30 of the time 20 of the time so
that they will continue to be asked to
play yeah you want to be otherwise yeah
you want to be a winner kind of what's
going on you want to be a winner not
just like you don't want to just destroy
everyone you want to win in a way that
will let you play like like win the most
times
that's sort of where i'm i'm like kind
of you know tuning right in right now
you can beat everybody with every
character yeah yeah and then but then
let them win like every like you know
every once in a while every once in a
while yeah yeah i know how that feels
right like that was kind of like my
thoughts during the tournament too
[Laughter]
you know it's just like yeah just give
one away you got to let them have one
yeah let them have one is that your
strategy as well sam
no
i uh no i fight as hard as i can if i
lose i go out kicking and screaming
okay i'll say i'll actually
[Laughter]
little spoiler one thing that you
mentioned to me that i thought was
absolutely hilarious was the sound
effects that you made in the tournament
for psychological warfare on christian
yes i used a lot of sound effects
that is so funny to me it works pretty
well yes
once things get going and like you find
a flow and you're just like
yeah
you're just like shooting those little
blasters
so this is the problem
you were sound animating your gameplay
it was it was a coping mechanism
ultimately though for me like because
like i just like get so
what is it you get so much anxiety like
the very first time we ever had a
tournament my hands were shaking so hard
oh even though it was just like here's
me playing someone i've played before
nothing no big deal and i'm just like
yeah but it's the tournament well that's
good to know that you also get nervous
because i just in my mind i was like sam
and nico are in front of a camera so
much that they go into the tournament
and it's just like i'm just playing
another game because like i feel like
nico changes when the when the when the
lights come on with the tournament
because it's like
it's just he becomes so i mean he's
always pretty zen but he becomes like so
in and i'm like i'm like freaking out
and i'm like how is he so calm right now
um that's how he that's how he copes
with the nerves oh yeah that's how he
locks in
right now i appreciate that that uh
that ability because yeah it's uh
i used to race in uh college and i would
get super nervous before the races
because they're all you didn't race that
often so each one
really meant a lot
for how you were gonna do in the sport
did you have to recover for a long time
afterwards too
like mentally or
physically is that why you didn't race
that much
no you just there's not that many races
well yeah because they're really hard on
your body and so if there's races every
day they won't really count that much
yeah right right
um that too
and so that was my thing was to like try
to zen out
you know
and then but then once you're in the
race
it's like
predator mode you know
like you're hunting you're looking for
your spots you're looking for your
placement your turn
your chance to attack
you know making sure you have enough
left over to defend all that stuff
okay guys i've been out and about doing
the research i've listened to you i've
heard your comments and i've got my
binoculars because i've been looking far
and wide for where you can get the best
stock assets in all of the internet and
i gotta say courtesy of today's sponsor
storyblocks i think i've finally done it
because it's the one-stop shop for all
of your stock asset needs now they have
a virtually unlimited library of high
quality 4k video audio images after
effects templates and more and you can
get it all through their cost-effective
subscription plans hey look at that is
that an unlimited all-access plan that's
going to allow you to download as much
as you want from the site
whenever you want and use it in
any kind of content that you want my
goodness it's all royalty free you can
use it in commercial projects or in
personal projects or in movies or
whatever you want oh my goodness and
what's that over there
no way
that's an enterprise plan if you're part
of a creative team and you guys aren't
using storyblocks talk to your team
leader about getting an enterprise plan
from storyblocks i can't tell you how
many times that corridor the first thing
that we do is go onto storyblocks and
see if they have stock assets that help
us tell the story that we're already
imagining in our heads it's amazing if
you're interested head on over to
storyblocks.comcast
and you can get signed up or click the
link in the description below that's
storybox.comcast and man hey
maybe that's you i see out there
it is you
you're clicking the link in the
description below
no wait you're signing up look at you
look at that oh man i can see it
now the future really is brighter
yeah that's super interesting dude it's
it's so crazy how deep you can get into
anything that's competitive because it's
like
you're literally looking for those tiny
percentages like
and that's why that's why you know you
talk about like
we've been playing this game for like
three years you thought we'd be over it
by now but it's like everybody gets
better so then you're looking for that
like tiny percentage point that you can
like
take somebody you know or psychological
warfare yeah actually yeah
the psychologists
skills no longer matter yeah
if you can't yeah if you can't follow
through with them
cyborgs
mind
technique
yes the mind well
i'm even more glad to announce that nick
and i as proud anti-smashers
um
and
antisma
um
we got a
we got a chess table
and jake you know we just we just set it
up and jordan and i played a game they
broke it in
you can't wait a minute
wait there there's a rule you can't play
chess unless
you can't play chess unless you're not
playing smash that day i thought you
need to be here to play chess so how's
this you and nick
because he's gonna work
we are going to put each egg next to the
board i can ask jordan coleman to make
moves for me if if necessary during when
i'm not there
you could be like i can't ask you to
make moves move my queen here and then
you say to him also a checkmate
and he has to walk with that knowledge
to the chessboard
knowing he's going to be a checkmate
that is a true walk of shame right there
that is psychological warfare there are
ways to play remotely but also this game
is intended to be a long con game where
the games go on for as long as they have
to so
if i'm in town and nick and i start a
game and we don't finish that game well
then guess what that game lives until
no one else can touch the board until
the next time the hell the game is done
and we'll have a list we'll put a list
next to to say who's facing who you know
who's got ups
and uh that's it that's for the all the
anti-smashers out there if you want to
join up you know but it there is the
there is a there is a catch
if you're in a chess game can't play
smash that's the catch for that limited
window or forever
i'm going to get a lord of the rings for
as long as your game is for as long as
your game is going on for
and if you're playing chess you can't
play lord of the rings risk
okay fair
go ahead
go ahead also more people can play that
but see jacob i think you're kind of
jazzed about this idea this is this is
very inspiring yeah yeah there's
something to this but just like put it
next to the other game boards when you
walk in and yeah yeah definitely
there'll be a selection of board games
that you can join
yeah we can play some i get to be elves
i just call them elves
all the time
sam is
constant elves
or wussies
i'll be an int
do you think the ants are i mean
hold on pulling up my phone
yeah
so that's
i'm excited for people to play chess um
but uh
that's you know what's another we'll put
a house rules board next to it is
another one of your secret ways to get
us to
stop playing smash
this first person peter for sure make
that game
ultimately we are still playing a game
though it's true instead of working it's
important i know
i didn't say that i just think you know
chess you can get up you can make a move
you can go back to your desk that's it
it's like it goes from like maybe
a 20-minute smash session to like a
two-minute move
but what if you take like 20 minutes to
take a move
listen this didn't come out of spite for
smash maybe it did but when it came out
of
what it ultimately came out of his nick
and i wanted a game of our own yeah i'm
happy for you guys i'm really happy for
you guys it seems like daniel's gonna
enjoy it too he yeah he plays jess so
yeah daniel chase might be in on it
occasionally
i'll jump in for a day i watched queen's
gambit once
okay there you go so you probably know
everything there's to know about chat
pretty much yeah yeah
right made the download how did your
research go
uh very expensive
it's out of print so it's like 200 bucks
oh my god
yeah that's a rare board
it's rare bored
all right but anyways um i wanted to
have dean and matt on to podcast today
because uh also they are working on two
different projects right now
that are
kind of
they're they're in line with things
we've done before but
maybe there's
you know spider-man definitely is
turning into something that's kind of in
a realm of its own i think for yeah well
yeah
it's a little bit of a hybrid between
some things that we've done but uh
because we sought out to make a
spider-man rated r in line with what's
going to be spider-man weekend at
corridor digital it's going to be
vfx artists react to spider-man 2's
only twos
and then uh spider-man rated r on court
or crew on sunday and then
sam are we going to release not
spider-man publicly
perhaps
most likely most likely
most likely we have danny gonzalez's
blessing so
we're gonna release it i think we're
gonna release not spider-man the hidden
if you saw what was that
what was that video that we put out
recently oh we put out so we put out the
andrew garfield that's right breaking
down
the leaked footage that he was in at the
end of that video there's some there's a
little snippet of not spiderman like one
shot
it's uh
beautiful it's like you know in the
avengers when it shows all the avengers
like jumping in it's like that tear of
[ __ ] right it's that time
yeah
so we're going to put out the full thing
i think it might just go on the website
but i don't know yet it's i feel like
that's a good website like
like bonus
right there get your not supposed to
anyways that's as far as we've thought
it through
as you can tell
um so anyways matt
we talked about
hey let's do spider-man rated r and then
yeah and then the wheels just started
coming off going on i don't know they're
kind of wheels returning started wheels
were coming off they go round and round
a little bit more of just like oh you
know we'll just do some of what we've
done in previous rated rs where it's
just like a kind of a clip show of
different you know r-rated scenes and
stuff but then sam was like hey we
should we should make a story about you
know spider-man we should do something
with this something else a little bit
layered yeah and i'm not trying to be
like too
yeah i don't mean i'm not trying to
impose too much but like i agree with
you right right i agree with you like
the truly like
i feel like still the most memorable
ones have been the ones that you can
watch
alone without all the context of us
yeah making them and working on them
yeah
and the thing is when you said it it
immediately got me more excited about
the project because
it leads to more creativity about like
what you can do with it and there's
plenty you can do with the multiverse
because it's just it opens the doors to
so much and marvel has given us these
amazing gems of storylines which um
to me to me i thought the best one that
dealt with the multiverse is loki yeah
um the tva is a really cool just idea
just general atmosphere and concept and
i i really thought that would be cool to
play with so
um so in the show they're called the
time ver
get over here get on the ground
we're taking you to school right now
we're compensating your clock that's
what's from last week
this remember last week that joke about
clocks
look at this look at this yeah sure
enough hey we came right up to this
house we thought it could be dangerous
good thing they didn't try anything but
our instincts were right as soon as we
walked inside look at this
whole table of clocks right here
hoarding time
hoarding time
yeah so
anyways for the
for the audience what is the the context
here of the of the multiverse stuff
you're talking about um with spiderman
rated r yeah um i won't don't give too
much away either but like
very basically it's like in our in the
latest uh
uh spider-man um no way home trailer um
we've seen that uh spider-man has
disrupted the multiverse right
it has been disrupted in some way that
we don't really know entirely why they
probably don't entirely explain either
oh maybe not i would certainly not in
the trailer um but we can assume some
things and i think that like it actually
does lead to more like well we can just
kind of you know make our own version of
what this might look like what what like
would happen
if spider-man were to do this if peter
parker you know disrupted this
multiverse um and my thought here was
well now we have this new reality of a
tva
and with our character mobius owen
wilson
um wow and owen wilson's still around
right at the end of loki won't spoil
anything else but owen wilson wow still
around wow um so i figured let's have a
look wilson
just
go around and uh
because well see what happens is uh
spider-man uh disrupts the multiverse
and creates a whole
series of these uh terrible versions of
spider-man uh that are just just
hideous at their jobs because in a true
multiverse you would have the worst
spider-man yeah so we have we have
somewhere from yeah from from this nexus
event that happens there's these like
branching timelines of horrible spider
men doing horrible things and it's up to
mobius to uh prune these timelines right
and uh uh
creating just one uniform timeline and
he does he does or does it
or does he
yeah that's the question this video will
answer
that's funny with lots of gore and blood
and violence and things happen
are we doing the uh owen willin
olsen wilson
yeah are we doing the impersonator
yes
yes i'm really excited about this um
okay
i think i i think we should we'll leave
that as well save that there is a there
is yes we're gonna get an owen wilson
impersonator who can do the voice very
well not just anybody but not just
anyone yeah a very special it's actually
it's owen wilson i think we could say
that okay
we're bringing it up did you wait hold
on did you guys know
hold on let me just just types it out
he's asking no no no no this is
something i discovered the other day
maybe this is common knowledge but it
wasn't to me
all right how many wilson brothers are
there
we got luke
we got
oh
i hope yeah owen i hope he's a part of
his um brotherhood
is there like a
mark or something
there's a guy named andrew wilson who's
the angel who's
or something do they all sound the same
maybe
andrew jackson was a president dean
andrew wilson
yeah and but the thing is is he
you know no offense to this guy but i
can tell by looking at him why he's not
a known actor
um because it's like you got luke wilson
you know he's like
charming handsome you know tall dark and
handsome and then you got owen wilson
who's like kind of quirky but he's got
enough charm to get away with it yeah
and then he got away and then you got
andrew wilson and and
he's kind of like a
like if the wilson brothers had a
brother that was jaws
from oh really on films but like you
know not that ugly but he's definitely
he's
do you know what he does he's like he's
not the most handsome one that's all i'm
saying he's not he's not a terrible
looking person but yeah so he's a getter
the moxie level is just not as high you
know that's all i'm saying there's also
uh the hemsworth brothers this is the
same situation there's chris hemsworth
thor
there's liam hemsworth who was in like a
bunch of high-profile movies yeah and
then there's like another there's like a
third hemsworth who's like if you watch
westworld he's like basically
yeah yeah it's like yeah he's like a
security guard it just wasn't quite the
vibe
hollywood was going for yeah and he's
like a very good looking dude but like
if your brothers are chris and the
pinnacle of man yeah like you're
literally one of your brothers thor
yeah
like you could be a good leader you
gotta get a loki if one of your brothers
is thor exactly yeah wait that's also
how the jonas brothers are because one
of them is uh
yeah this is a thing this is a thing
with brothers of three if you have three
brothers
there's four oh wow yeah christian used
to work well the fourth one was actually
the ugliest one yeah
for a reason right in the garbage with
that one yeah so anyway no offense to
any of these people i've all i'm saying
is like you know really
i'm sure they're listening
in the acting world it's like
the way that you look obviously has a
plays a role in the roles you get and
i don't know i guess that's just the way
that it is you know yeah it's like 90
percent of the job it's like
do you or do you look the part do you
say is your voice one thing i don't sam
did you say this the other day or was it
nico but it was like cast for the voice
yeah look that stuck with me when he
said it like because when we were
shooting um that uh that lightsaber
video uh
it was the same thing that he was
casting
yeah
and that that is that is true i think
there's there's some truth in that for
sure
yeah because a lot of people that do
really well
in the acting world not you know you
typically yeah they're probably good
looking and whatnot but more often than
that they also have a way of speaking
that's kind of
uncommon i think to you know
stand in
the dialect you got benedict cumberbatch
you got uh i mean chris uh
christopher walken's like the classic
example right and jeff goldblum like
yeah
like it's like they
they try to deliver a line
in a way that is like makes you go why
would you say it like that right now
yeah and john wayne used to do that too
sure what i noticed about owen wilson um
from my hours of watching
owen wilson listening to his voice and
you've seen all of his stuff
watch all of this this was before yeah
this was before the spider-man project
yes there's just mo matt yeah yeah this
is just kind of my thing is i just study
owen wilson's voice
for days and days he's like
looking in the mirror he's like so crazy
wow
wow just in the dark
just so i can pretend like he's there
with me
um
anyway
anyway um
one thing i noticed after my
years of research is that um owen
wilson's when he uh is supposed to give
like a really passionate performance if
there's a scene that is like heightening
and drama and intensity he tends to do
the opposite thing that most actors
would do which is raise their voice he
actually goes lower he'll like he'll
start like whispering like this he's
[Music]
you know
that's true yeah it is very you pay more
attention to it you pay more attention
to it i didn't really know that kids is
called moxie that's called moxie ladies
and gentlemen yeah that's called mocks
it's that genesecua it's really jazzed
on moxie
mm-hmm yeah
yeah there's some weird weird actors out
there
so we're putting that together and it's
coming out big spider-man weekend dean
did you know they announced the release
date of no way home
the release date has been around for a
while no i thought wait i thought they
were withholding that jake's like
no i mean
that's like december behind yeah yeah
december 17th
that's been known for like i think
probably months at this point well fine
okay
guess i'm not that into spiderman no way
home release dates oh no dude i'm so
into it that trailer dropped and like we
pulled it up on the on the 80-inch lg
yeah we were watching it breaking down
every shot no i'm very excited for that
movie but i i guess that wasn't that was
a very stupid statement of me because
they do that all the time they release
dates months in advance
otherwise they'll be kind of stupid
[Laughter]
guys christmas has come early to the
corridor cast courtesy of today's
sponsor manscape now if you can't see
what's in front of me well they've got a
whole selection of products just in time
for the holiday season including a brand
new body wash and two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner as well as the performance
package 4.0 oh now a bunch of great
products in here and i got to tell you
all about them because if you use the
code cord or cast at checkout you can
get 20 off any of these products plus
free shipping 20 off plus free shipping
so first and foremost they're going
beyond the groin this holiday with a
ultra premium body wash courtesy of
manscape this is a brand new product
from them they also hey they said why
not just do body wash let's do a two in
one shampoo and conditioner so not only
are you going to clean your scalp you're
also going to moisturize it because if
you don't know that's what conditioner
is for took me years to learn that but
that's not all they also have the weed
whacker which is always available for
your nose your ears and wherever else
you need a weed whacker and they've got
this amazing package the performance
package 4.0 this comes with their
signature lawnmower trimmer with the
lockable travel switch the super intense
led light so you can see in those hard
to reach places and with that patented
skin safe technology which is going to
make sure that you don't suffer from any
slices while you're doing your business
the performance package 4.0 also
includes the crop preserver and crop
reviver which is the anti-chafing
deodorant moisturizer and toner which is
going to keep you feeling and smelling
fresh all day long in addition this
hygiene bundle comes with a pair of
manscaped anti-shaving boxers none of
these boxes will keep you feeling
comfortable all day and they're really
the perfect thing to go with this
perfect package for your perfect package
really so if you guys are interested in
getting your hands on any of these goods
head on over to manscapes.com and use
the code corridor cast at checkout for
20 off plus free shipping 20 off
free shipping get it for whoever you
need it's a great gift for a company
that specializes in these products just
for you huge thanks to them for
sponsoring the podcast they make a great
trimmer and a bunch of other great stuff
too so anyways thanks to them and now
back to the episode
yeah hey listen i i've got my i've got
my blind spots
no doubt i mean marvel marvel can get
away with that though they could
announce a movie like the day before it
comes out it would still make a billion
dollars
yeah
seriously
yeah so that's gonna be uh
it's gonna be big but i'm excited i'm
more excited for what we're gonna do
around that world than what marvel's
gonna do let's be honest yeah yeah
that's gonna be fun
yeah and um
wait actually sam did you say there was
some frustrating things
that were going on
in your life today
regarding spider-man it's not
i i'm trying to see if there's like an
interesting angle on it
if there isn't you know we can we can
hard pivot i'm
like
simulations that are glitching out
constantly and crashing and it's just
like
i spent like three days
basically working on and off and i don't
have like a single like usable oh man
thing right now are you were you trying
to do them in unreal
no or no
just i i was i'm applying the old tiny
guns too technique the spider-man
and yeah just falling apart yeah so
we'll see it could be uh
i'll render out whatever it is
it might just be like really weird and
glitchy looking we definitely need shots
yeah they're important just throw owen
wilson in the foreground and you're good
we need violence in this um have you
guys seen all the new spider-man movies
or the the two new ones
yep what do you think of them
they're um entertaining hey hell yeah
they are i also really like the um uh in
the second new spider-man uh the
um
uh all that like vfx stuff
yeah the vfx village like the villain
is so much fun to me i really like all
the visual effects wow i just love the
visual effects you know the vfx and
marvel movies are like pretty good
yeah but you know they got the it's uh
um because i've it's really good i feel
like
they are
they kind of fundamentally misunderstand
the character of spider-man it feels
like like
you know
like that's that's harsh criticism i
don't want to hear about it it's weird
because they're fun movies
but like
it feels like high school kid
who puts on a spider-man costume it's
not like right because like the you know
if you watch the toby maguire movies you
read the comics it's like
the the thing about peter parker is that
his life
sucks like his life
is is made much worse by being
spider-man and in these new movies it
always feels like he's like i'm just i'm
going on vacation or like i'm like
hanging out and having a good time
and uh
i just feel like these new movies have
kind of like
and i feel like this is the thing with a
lot of the a lot of the marvel movies is
they kind of just make it like it's just
light fun and there's not like you know
i like these right well they
they don't want to have anybody like
they don't want to have any offense
about it at all whatsoever so they can't
even like say like
spider-man is actually burdened
by
his superpower and it's like
he doesn't
know what to do with it and he's
struggling with it
so
you want like a zack snyder spider-man
movie basically yeah yeah no it's like
it's very dark and he's burdened no the
toby mcgregor is like the tobey mcguire
movies he like
he like
has to pay his rent and like he's late
on his rent because he was being
spider-man and he was like you know he's
got to work at this freaking pizza place
and you know in the new movies he's like
yeah i'm an avenger and i get all my uh
tony stark awesome stuff and you know
right
yeah i mean that's that's marvel you
know that's that's this that's the
corporate blockbuster model that's just
what it is they're like we need to reach
the largest audience that is
feasible
and we mean this globally like how can
we get as many people on the globe to
watch this movie so
we're just gonna round it off there
round it off there listen you'll you'll
probably walk out of it and go sam's
reaction yeah yeah it was it was
entertaining yeah
but you went and you paid us and
therefore
our model worked and that's like but did
it because the last couple haven't
weren't approved to play in china so
it's like
they kind of like
the mark there
yeah but it's fine that's plenty of
other people but
yeah
hey sam can i ask you a question yeah um
were you more jazzed when you walked out
of
spiderman jazz were you more jazzed when
you walked in you got to get quieter
spiderman can i ask the question
jake
were you more jazzed
when you walked out of the new
spider-man movie or paw patrol
uh well i saw it's a little different
because i i saw both of them like
just like at home oh really i didn't see
either
theater
when i came out of paw patrol i was
super jazzed
i know you were like hyped on it the
next day it worked i was like you're
like talking to us about it i mean no
entertaining once again it's
entertaining yeah but it's more of the
experience yeah you know yeah you're
going through a movie with a three or
three-year-old who screams every time
their cars transform right you know
you were you were more into the
spectacle of pawn patrol
paw patrol yeah did your kids watch
super wings
no super links okay super wings is like
transformers
like you know kind of it's like these
yeah it's like transformers for younger
and they're they go around and they help
other machines and people and stuff and
so they transform from like planes to
anim anamorphic type
planes and um
and so they can transfer to a plane with
like ears
you know what i mean
um and so
jj was watching one uh yesterday and
there's like a character that he wanted
to see in it and then
you know they have the main character
and then the main character always gets
paired up to go on an adventure with one
of his buddies and they paired him up
with this one and jj was like
and this kid's only three mind you and
he goes oh man
not dizzy i wanted astra oh
jeez
i couldn't believe it though but he
already is so into the show and has and
already has that
yeah that emotion and he's only three
well
yeah
um so he was obviously not jazzed about
that
not just at all
but uh
yeah anyways dean you've been working on
another video
that sure had yeah and i also have been
working on it yeah
yeah yeah we're working on it too yeah
yeah covertly
ops been working on it yeah dude covert
matt over here yeah covert matt they
wanted me to help with the filming of it
anyway yeah i'm splicing up um
brandon and jordan are hard at work on
the vfx for uh
this jurassic park video we are
perhaps recreating one of the most
famous vfx shots of all time certainly
one that on vfx arts react maybe comes
up every episode
uh the the t-rex in the rain scene from
jurassic park which right from the
original 94
original i think it was 94 was a 93
either way they made the shot
yeah they did the shows yeah
yeah uh i i watched uh jurassic park for
the first time two nights ago i've never
seen really well what did you think of
it
pretty good
so that's like a dinosaur
spiderman interesting spider-man
reaction interesting it's pretty good
that's pretty good i see you didn't you
didn't think it was you wouldn't go as
far as to say it was good
the dress park yeah
no it's it's good movie i just think i
feel like
people hype it up you know it's like
pretty solid movie
you know i mean it's pretty incredible
movie it's kind of incredible right it's
would you say it's incredible they
brought dinosaurs back to life
they actually did that practically but
uh
on an island yeah hawaii because i get
it but that's
i i agree like again this was like lucky
with paw patrol the spectacle of it was
was very impressive with paw patrol
and um it does like there is a thing
which ren
goes into depth on in the video is that
there is just
despite the fact that cg is done in 93
it's like very early
and there are some times where it looks
a little janky if things are out in
broad daylight or you know that sort of
thing
there is an approach to it
that
is just not taken today which is
this
cg we're going to use it as a tool just
as we would in animatronic or just as we
would you know a miniature it's not
the
you know the entire meal it's not the
steak and potatoes you know it's like
yeah it's just another tool in the
toolbox and that's what i think you know
people's
people say it
still holds up today you know
watching it i was like yeah this totally
still holds up today and it's and it's
because of that um and i think the the
the goal of the video i think is to
recreate this shot but to also show
people
or to
celebrate
that groundbreaking nature of the movie
you know
and uh do you feel like it's do you feel
like it's getting there in terms of
doing that
yeah you know i have a i have a clear
shot from my desk over and over jordan's
shoulder and uh he's slapped um
we got one of the world's greatest smoke
actors in to the studio um
yeah i mean like
definitely
you know andy circus like has studied
him very closely
um
and so he came in to do the performance
of the t-rex that's going to be a fun
part of the video yeah this guy's kind
of fundamental sort of like foundational
type inspiration for some of the other
emotions he's been around for so long
yeah which actually uh
a bit of a detour but daniel is doing a
crew cuts video about uh another mobile
actor we have in the studio who actually
you could say
was a mocap actor before andy circus
ever put on
he was
yeah worthless actor before andy circus
ever put on a mocap suit so
our studio and that was young nikki
laurent yeah and uh
daniel has a whole video going into his
background and his groundbreaking work
as uh
as a mocap actor and in the mummy
returns
with childhood factor yep yeah yeah
which usually their career is
kind of spiraling yeah they end soon
well guess what [ __ ] was just doing
mocap in the video once again so
or noticed he didn't have on the suit
no but he like he brought out the same
sort of performance that we brought that
we've that we know and love from the
mummy returns you know the the pygmy the
screaming you know when he pops out of
the
bushes
you mean the mummy returns starring
nichola nicki actually sorry jake it's
so nikki was his name when he was a
child uh
yep
sort of when like sam said things sort
of fell apart and then he took on the
name nick to sort of separate that time
in his life i know it's crazy though so
you don't want to go back to calling him
nikki
yeah no
when we were filming react with adam
savage
nick like finally he was like hey do you
know like alex laurent and adam's like
yeah like completely we've worked
together for years on tons of stuff
like on everything and and he's like
yeah that's my dad and he adam's like
holy crap
what
like
like
he knows nick's dad really well
very well they've been working on many
projects together oh that's funny
yeah and so i thought that was super
super funny so like when nick was doing
the mummy mocap like adam was working on
the movie as well
oh okay wow wow yeah wow
okay what did he work on on the monkey
returns we didn't we we didn't get too
deep into
well that was the first mummy oh so much
i bet you it was the oasis
yeah i wasn't i didn't get into
the specifics with what he was working
on on the moment we didn't actually go
into that that movie at all yeah but uh
it's my understanding that adam savage
did the did some of the child mocap
lemur acting
alongside nikki
in the mummy returns well they caught
him by facts right yeah but they cut him
out because
you know they got so many great top
shows nick it was a tough it was a tough
battle
tough thing to decide but
kind of still i think yeah yeah i think
that's what happens
sam people might be interested in that
uh we had someone named adam savage in
the studio yeah i guess oh yeah that's
not out yet yeah yeah it's just it's out
now it's out now well no we posted the
info is out now the infoset
yeah yeah that was pretty cool he's
super super
knowledgeable
i mean like you like for me anyways
for years i was like yeah super cool guy
mythbusters love all the stuff he's
doing he's doing this tested show on
youtube i get that
and then like i knew there was like all
right there's like underlying
film industry stuff
you know that kind of connected everyone
but i never
knew too much of those details i was
like okay they have a movie background
but
actually now sitting down and talking
with them it's like oh like we're
talking like
star wars prequels matrix movies
and then
like those being the big ones and then
everything else
being the other projects so
um it's pretty cool he's yeah very like
comfortable and really passionate the
film i would say a film historian in a
lot of ways because of his
you know just i saw i saw his ted talk
on the it opens with the maltese falcon
and he's talking about that like his at
least his um attention to
to the production design and like of of
just the films that he loves and it's
like it's so
molecular his like interest there
yeah totally i mean he was saying i mean
he he was like the star wars generation
so it's like he was like he was like 10
when he saw star wars and so basically
from that you know that point in cinema
forwards
he's just been obsessed so manages to
like pick up every detail
even from pieces he doesn't work on just
because of the amount of research and
like the fascination he has with
everything so
yeah
it was it was like overloading i'd say
actually doing that episode because we
had some stuff planned but at the same
time
we would reference one thing and he'd be
like here's like three fun facts about
three totally different movies
that do similar things and then he just
like starts going off the like the deep
end with all that stuff and
so
most of the episode like kristen's doing
his his best to keep up with like
keeping like relevant clips playing but
like yeah like
75 of the conversation was just just
three guys on the couch talking about
movies yeah you know like totally like
we weren't watching stuff and for like
much of it it was just like we'd see a
clip and like that's sweet we talk about
it and then it'd be like here's
yeah five other subjects let's talk
about that and
yeah it was it was a little all over the
place and intense but uh really really
interesting he seems super jazzed about
about the experience yeah yeah
yeah i think
i'm glad that you guys were able to like
really get into
the stuff that he's interested in though
yeah well i mean like we're all really
into i mean a big part of it i think was
also just you know he walks in and he's
like
here's a bunch of cool film facts and
running myself we're like whoa yeah
really that's enough yeah and he's like
yeah
and then he's like how about this did
you know this is
another one
i got more of those kids so we're just
like constantly doing that throughout
the whole thing because yeah
that's awesome that's great yeah he has
so much and like we barely scraped the
surface there he was definitely
one of those people
like uh
wren kind of brought him upstairs on the
tour and i kind of turned and i'm like
i i would thought i was like i'm going
to be cool about this
and i'm like oh my god there's inside
i'm savage like i grew up with my
sponsors and i like
they're like guys this is adam and i was
like hi
[Laughter]
you would rehearse how you're gonna say
hi for a couple of minutes yeah
everybody was leaving i was like
[Laughter]
but yeah that was really sweet
he got a
he got to talk to natalie too who's a
huge fan and yeah he's a he's a really
nice guy
awesome
that's great yeah um
well you know what they say if if you uh
if you're the smartest guy in the room
you got to find another room you know
and that's just it's
awesome to find people that want to come
on the show
that's a joke for you jake was about to
yeah he's joking about leaving yeah
he's brilliant
he's brilliant
um so no that's cool that it's really
cool to see that there's people that
want to come on that have
a depth of understanding and knowledge
and experience that's
just
you know makes you feel small
like it's that's a good thing you know
yeah well no for real though because
like that was the first time i think any
guest has been at that level of like
coming in and being like hey what's up
i i i really know more than you guys do
or like or at least about
a certain number of things here you know
when it comes to a lot of these films
because previously you know when we have
like vfx supervisors on
uh very frequently it's like we're like
hey yeah uh so what's the deal with this
shot and they're like well
there's like uh i think we did there's
like a 3d model
we put in there and then the compositors
took that and then uh yeah
wrapped the shot up
and we're like okay
like yeah like what was like the
challenge with the shot you know like
we're
um i think bro brian grills
brian grill i think was
like i think sorry he is the he's
actually the first guest of being like i
can actually break this stuff down and
like
give you like dish out the info i'm like
how do you construct this shot yeah um i
think also though a lot of times people
don't have that
communicator
skill set and then like so if it's just
uh
you know a vfx who hasn't been on that
many shows or like hasn't really had to
communicate it that much they have very
like
they have that sort of insider knowledge
but they don't
know what people don't know about
visual effects so it's like they're kind
of like talking about it as if they're
like these guys already know what i'm
talking about and i think there's
there's a certain level to which like
adam of course has like trained this
over years is like yeah i
know what people don't know and i know
how to get from where i'm at to where
they're at yeah yeah
i mean yeah it's i think that's that's
definitely a huge part of it it's like a
balance of that and then the whole like
uh
it's like you have like an actual
baseball player versus
like the owner of the team yeah you know
thing where it's like yeah i like i know
all the rules and i know what all the
positions are i can i can explain
everything that's happening here but you
give me a bat and like i'm gonna or
admit or whatever
not gonna perform sports doesn't know
actually how to do it and like that
that's like that level of
of like information
the practitioner knowledge but that's
what makes the i think that's what makes
that show interesting in my opinion is
because it's
it's like all right like
how do you do it yeah like don't explain
like the the top view like let's let's
imagine we're gonna make it ourselves
i think that's a super super super super
important part of the show but i do
think like having people that
come from different walks
in the experience in the process
does make overall the show as a library
like more robust and interesting
personal yeah yeah yeah oh totally yeah
i mean i'm not yeah i don't want to get
too
like down on that kind of stuff either
because like once again adam savage kind
of happens to be one of those people of
our time who happens to be a great
public speaker and presenter and host
yeah and then
has that like in the trenches knowledge
yeah
yeah and that's like this is the first
like sfx
kind of guy that's been on the show
right yeah which is it's a unique
perspective and it also keeps the show
fresh because it's not you know it's not
just a bunch of vfx guys like how did
they do this computers it was like
there's like this time
yeah
it's like we've got we put mylar on it
and then we shined a red light from the
yeah yeah
yeah it's cool
that's awesome yeah
yeah the most fun fact fun fact though
i'm just i gotta say yeah the most fun
fact that
i learned during the show was
um apparently in model making so when
you kit bash stuff or you create things
you know you have these things called
greebles which are just tiny little
pieces you put everywhere to add detail
but um frequently actual like actual
plastic model kits that you buy in
stores
you know for fun yeah are abused in this
process and so it happens that there is
like one
specific piece
called the universal grebel because
they just find it super useful to use
all the time and then it's in like a
spaceship model kit from the 70s or 80s
yeah that they're still producing
and and it's like one of the most
commonly used
pieces in model making in making
miniatures
and uh adam's gonna look this up
adam was using it
he uh he was building like a like a
russian satellite for the movie space
cowboys
and he put them on there
and then
so he made this miniature model and so
then they're going hey we need to make a
life-size version of this for the actors
to walk around in on the scene so they
go they look at his miniature model and
in the in the movie itself
uh they've they take this these tiny
little plastic things from model kits
and replicate them to life size
when you look at the like the full scale
model it's like oh like this is
hilarious like literally we're looking
at just like a big toy
yeah
i would have taken that piece of the set
and like mounted it
at ilm somewhere or something yeah right
that's like the kind of thing you need
to do it's like we literally we took
this thing like we shrunk a spaceship
down into this little piece yeah and
then it like made its way back up yeah
man i made the whole life cycle yeah i
know you'd put that that you put that up
on the wall in the model shop
that's so cool
i wish i had that comes up as his video
uh going into that that's awesome
yeah it's such a cool skill set to have
for him as like because i watch his his
channel all the time and like
just
like again that like attention to detail
like have you ever seen that video he
made the blade runner gun
yeah like
the amount of research just into that
one piece like the amount of history
that goes into it it's it's really
beautiful like to put uh like to have
that much like love for
such a what you would think is just such
a small thing in the film but like sure
it's really i know i can only imagine
what his house is like it's just like
display cases
on every wall
he probably has a ton of awesome display
cases that he's like the opposite of a
minimalist he's like maximalist he's a
maximalist yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
it's so funny it's like yeah the marie
kondo thing it's like if it does if you
don't feel something when you pick it up
you know you get rid of it and it's like
no i feel yeah everything he's like
about everything he's like this was in a
1927 film
[Laughter]
um
so yeah i i we probably could have
started the podcast with hey we had adam
savage on
vfx artistry act
but uh
there you have it
well
instead we just did mic checks
that was probably fun for you listener
thank you well i think it just goes to
show there's like so much cool stuff
happening around here all the time that
you know sometimes we forget some cool
stuff sometimes we forget guys there's
just things are happening yes
so cool
i don't know you know i just can't keep
track of it all we're just getting we're
just jamming
we're just jazzed up a lot and it's
that's just what it is just gets me just
it's yours
it's a little slow
sorry sorry all right last question uh
are you guys excited for secret santa
this year because last year we made
jordan cry
yeah clint clinton made jordan cry with
a hand-drawn
uh thing of every character from the
office well now it's pretty lame if
somebody gets her something from the
office so they got to figure out
something else
clint kind of ruined that for everybody
didn't he yeah
yeah is there like a secret agent angle
we can take on this like like
nobody is secret
top secret
it's not secret santa it's
top secret sandwich like you have to
sneak the present into somewhere they'll
find it without them knowing
i don't know
maybe we should call the video that top
secret santa and it's like and then do a
little intro
where there's like a secret agent
montage at the beginning
no yeah anyway
oh top secret santa's upstairs if you
can't see santa who gave it to you it
gets destroyed you don't get it
that's amazing if the item
self-destructs in 10 seconds if you
can't
[Laughter]
one bitcoin
yeah
oh
man um all right cool well um
thanks for jumping in on the
conversations gentlemen and uh it was my
pleasure
i don't know what you guys are doing for
thanksgiving but um enjoy it and um
you know
and enjoy the enjoy the day
i'll give thanks that's what i'll do yes
do some things that's right eat some
delicious food
i love thanksgiving son it's it's good
it's a good time for me
yeah i agree it's a good time get the
family together have a good time
that's right you know argue about
something
always always
never stop arguing with your family
that's that's rule number one exactly
keeps it fresh
all right sam any last words
you haven't said much in this podcast
[Laughter]
that's it
all right
well fine you guys ready oh i'm ready
[Music]
to be cut yet